vous savez bon même s'il vient de
changer de ministre de l'intérieur il
suffit de discuter avec les forces de
sécurité avec les policiers sur le
terrain pour voir à quel point ils sont
écoeurés décourager de cette aversion
qu'il y a des valeurs dans notre pays
aujourd'hui
vous parliez de laxisme vous parliez de
hausse de la délinquance qui est une
réalité
les homicides ont augmenté de près de
huit et demi pour cent en rythme annuel
on atteint pratiquement les 1000
homicides par an c'est gravissime dans
notre pays en matière de réponse pénale
vous avez un nouveau ministre de la
justice qui a été nommé à cette fonction
je pense à maître dupond-moretti le
premier déplacement qui fait c'est
d'aller dans les prisons et de parler en
premier des détenus et en second il
parle du personnel pénitentiaire
là aussi je veux dire à un moment il
ferait mieux de parler des victimes
parce que je crois que c'est de cela
qu'il faut parler en premier dit victime
des conditions de travail de ceux des du
personnel pénitentiaire il faut remettre
les peines planchers pour les
multirécidivistes
mais vous avez vu comment sont traités
les policiers dans les quartiers mais
c'est une honte absolue
donc il faut redonner à nos forces de
sécurité
l'autorité nécessaire et pour cela il
faut qu'il soit suivi par les
gouvernants parce que quand ils sont
lâchés par les gouvernants et bien qu'en
réalité ils sont découragés et c'est les
délinquants qui gagne le plan de
construction de prisons ne comptait pas
ce que monsieur dupont moretti continue
le plan de construction de deux prises
par ailleurs j'ajoute que tous ceux qui
font des actes de délinquance qui sont
sur notre territoire notamment les
déboutés du droit d'asile qu'on ne
rentrera pas chez eux qui sont des
multirécidivistes
là aussi c'est profondément scandaleux
moi je suis allé dans l'est dans un
centre de rétention administrative quand
je vois des délinquants sorti de prison
mi en centre de rétention administrative
pour être rapatriés dans leur pays
d'origine
eh bien ils sont pas rapatriés tant
qu'il n'y a pas de laissez passer
consulaires et quant aux délais dépassés
on les remet dans la rue mais si les
français savait ça mais il serait et que
ray et curé miam
on peut plus supporter tout ça tous ces
actes violents qu'on a dans notre pays
donc il faut vraiment et du poing sur la
table et avoir des actes forts alors
quand il parle d'incivilité franchement
parlant c'est de tous les environs ou de
délits majeurs tolérance zéro mais ils
utiles utilise le terme d'incivilité moi
je voudrais qu'ils disent qu'en matière
d'incidents sécurité il y aura de la
tolérance zéro et qu'il donnera une
vraie réponse panneaux forte et
puissante pour répondre à ce qui se
passe sur sur le terrain et il
soutiendra les forces de sécurité parce
que je peux vous dire qu'ils sont
écoeurés sur le terrain d'al khor